[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
like the video and comment hey guys in
this video we're going to talk about the
theory in which the green eyes are evil
shut forever are Cersei Lannister
after surviving Sunday's battle of NFL
game Aaron Spencer now focused on the
resurfaced season a three prophecy from
el Sanjay which seems to hint at the
upcoming demise of the green eyed Cersei
it all goes back to season 3 episode 6
when arya met Melisandre for the first
time I see a darkness in you the red
woman said and in the darkness eyes
staring back at me brown eyes blue eyes
green eyes eyes you'll shut forever
Melisandre also told Arya that they
would meet again a prediction that
finally came true in the long night
you said we would meet again or he
reminds her the prophecy you said I shut
many eyes forever you were right about
it to its most anti remaining Arya about
the other parts of their conversation
brown eyes green eyes and blue eyes that
leads her to realize that she's the one
who must kill the night king are you
confirmed to Melisandre that since they
last met she did indeed shut some
people's eyes forever specifically she
nodded to having killed a character with
brown eyes Walder Frey whom she killed
in the season 6 episode of insa winter
but at the time of our demos Sanchez
made the episode said she hadn't
dispatched any notable green or blue
eyed beings that she could recall of
course that changed by the end of an
episode when Aria killed a blue-eyed
night king destroying his army of the
Dead and saving the forces of the living
if the night King was the blue-eyed
victim and bolder Frey had brown eyes
who is the green eyed person milk Santa
references it just so happens that
Cersei Lannister a villain on the series
and the current occupant of the ar.drone
happens to have a pair of sparkling
emerald green eyes both in Georgia
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire Knowles
and on TV she is also the person Aria
was going to kill at King's Landing
before learning her family's of NFL and
living it for some other time most of
the name scenario skilless turn out that
some buyers handsome not her Achilles
now is relatively short sir a limp anus
executioner remains alive an actor will
coach Johnson was phased out of the show
after season two due to ill health
but having undergone successful
treatment for his illness it's possible
his character could return the helmet
appears to be off arias list now given
she actively fought to keep him alive in
the battle for Winterfell his zombified
brother the mountain however not so much
the final name still on the list of
course Cersei Lannister Circe is one of
the oldest name on our Aeschylus theater
she imprisoned her father back in season
1 and was present when her son Joffrey
ordered his beheading there's long
history of bad blood with Arya as
besides her involvement in capturing Ned
and beheading him also includes
conspiring to kill Nymeria aureus dire
wolf after her fight video for in season
one holding Sansa captain also when Arya
recited her killer sir she was number
two right behind her son Joffrey
Lannister with the night king out of the
way the remaining troops will be
marching to means landing for the final
showdown with Cersei so the wheels are
certainly in motion for Arya to be it
one to end her rule note the order of
Melisandre's words in season three she
mentions green eyes last she mentions
brown eyes first
Inara shut them down first she mentions
blue eyes second and Irish shuts them
next the night King finally
multi-dimensions green eyes it's
probably going to be sir saying the
upcoming episodes it seems like no
sanchez prophecy not only revealed who
are able to kill but also the exact
order of the killing we know that in
Episode four are able go on her own
mission to shut the green eyes search
his eyes and we know she would be
accompanied in the admission by the
Hound
I called it many times in the previous
videos Maisie Williams said this Ferrara
story for season eight there's this
split otário between trying to be who
she wants to be getting back to back to
that naivete and innocence with her
family and her unfinished business I was
correct when I predicted that what this
means is Atari will stick with her
family and fight for Manor fell against
the night king in Episode three which
she did but when she realizes that
Cersei is the final threat and her
family will not be safe as long as her
she lives she'll have to say a temporary
goodbye to her family a goal to finish
her infamous list the Hound will decide
to help Aria since with the mountain on
ray re will not be able to either kill
Cersei Orange
hence arrive upon killing Cersei Rory
McCain who plays the hand also hinted at
this and he gave us a hint at the
confrontation between the Hound and the
mountain by saying there will be a
chance of screwing up to his brother and
facing those demons long-anticipated
you'll between the mountain and the
hound often referred to by fans as
Campbell has seemingly been set for the
final season Cersei knows fully well
Danny would not use her dragons to burn
her inside the red cape if it means
thousands of innocent people would die
long saucers invites many citizens to
the red keep to hide behind their walls
from the incoming conqueror Danny
earning their loyalties but also
ensuring Danny will not use her dragons
to burn the entire red cape along with
her inside it once Ursa gets the small
folk inside red keep all the gates will
be closed and the walls meant by the
remaining Lannister soldiers yearns
Ironborn and the gauntlet company no one
gets out no one gets inside however that
will not represent any problem for our
end hound her on their mission to kill
sir send Mountain at first what comes to
mind is the target could simply kill the
guards and just walk in the red key
without a problem
just like Jackie hawk are killed all the
guards at Harrenhal and allowed Arya to
just walk out of the main gates even
though Arya could probably do the same
here she will go more stealthy approach
than this she will use the secret
passageways inside the red cape which
were not meant back in season one and
are most likely not meant now as well
I'm talking about the secret passage
into the red keep dungeons that Arya
found upon overhearing a conversation
between various and Illyrio back in the
very first season in case you don't
remember let me remind you that during
her cat chasing training exercise or you
found her way into the dungeons under
the red key where she saw the dragon
skulls and also her her delirium and
Varys floating about bringing Targaryen
giles back on the Iron Throne Arya then
found out about the secret way out of
the castle I believe are able to use
that same passage to sneak up inside the
red keep
where pawn shall go to Cersei chambers
to shut her green eyes once and for all
Cersei is the green eyes Daria needs to
shut forever and she will go on that
mission with the count who also has to
face his brother who happens to be
services personal guard
I really wish we'd see more of these two
as they travel south together but with
only two episodes left there is no time
for that
the next time you see them they'll be
sneaking inside read keep one sorry
auntie Helen sneak into the red keep the
two will go straight into sir Sir
chambers one would thing they would then
just break in and now it would wait for
the Hound to kill the mountain so she
can come closer to Cersei and killer but
I don't think that's how it's going to
play out it would make more sense for
Aria to kill Cersei and then the Clegane
Bowl plays out are you wearing KY burns
or even Jamie's face see bran does end
up killing Jamie comes close to Cersei
and avoids being killed by the mountain
and then she kills her just with the
mountain with joy sword to kill area for
shadow kill gamble will take place The
Hound would fulfill his promise that he
gave to the mountain in the season 7
finale it's not how it ends for your
brother you know who's coming for you
you've always known nothing can be said
for sure but there are definitely some
clues and hints supporting both are you
killing the green eyed Cersei and click
gamble that would follow up afterwards
Arya vote fulfilled the yet unfulfilled
prophecy that was told to her by
Melisandre she has brown eyes she has
blue eyes and finally she would shot
green eyes but how does this fit another
prophecy about Circe's demise that she
will be killed by her little brother a
youngster she was told by fortune-teller
Maggy the Frog that the valonqar should
wrap his sense about her pale white
throat and choke the life from her the
valonqar means little brother in
valyrian leading fans to assume that
Tyrion her possibly services to in Jaime
will prove to be her downfall
after all all the rest of Maggie's
prophecies the search they would not be
the prince rhaegar targaryen
but rather the King Robert Baratheon and
at her three children would all die
before her have all come sure it's
possible for both men Sanjay's prophecy
in Maggie's to be fulfilled if Arya very
Jamie's face is a disguise in order to
get close to Cersei
however the prophecy could still in
theory be fulfilled without his having
anything to do with Jaime not only could
the younger brother dwell on car be any
Malins story who has an older sibling
but it can also be any female in the
story who has an older sibling as well
the word valonqar comes from high
Valyrian a language that is not really
into gender specificities
as we learned in season 7 when we
learned the prince that was promised
could also translate as the princess
that was promised
so this younger brother could very well
be a younger sister
therefore the proper translation the
valonqar prophecy might also be
gender-neutral with the possibility of
both younger brother and younger sister
possible being the velum car and since
maggie doesn't specifically say sir say
your valonqar will kill you but the
valonqar will kill you it could pretty
much be anyone in story who has older
sibling including aria in conclusion
there's definitely a ton of evidence
supporting the idea of Orion Hound going
on their last final mission together
sneaking into the red cape using secret
passageways and killing the mountain in
the green eyed Cersei also let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below
stay tuned for all the season 8 episode
5 upcoming videos and theories are
coming this week we're going to talk
about versus betrayal as well as about
Erin's potential betrayal or Danny about
the golden company's betrayal and about
many more theories regarding sources
death and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace